Kurt Andersen: Como a muchos arquitectos, a David le gusta llamar la atención
pero es lo suficientemente reticente -- o al menos pretende serlo --
que me ha pedido que lo interrogue en vez de conversar.
De hecho, de lo que hablaremos,
pienso, es ciertamente un tema que es probablemente mejor servido
por una conversación que por un discurso.
Y supongo que tenemos un pequeño fragmento noticioso como anticipo.
Dan Rather: Desde el ataque del 11 de Septiembre en el World Trade Center,
muchas personas han visitado Nueva York en masa para presenciar,
y presentar sus respetos, a lo que se constituye en un cementerio de 16 acres.
Ahora, como reporta Jim Axelrod de CBS, se ponen los toques finales
a una nueva manera para que la gente visite y admire la escena.
Jim Axelrod: Olviden el Edificio Empire State o la Estatua de la Libertad --
hay un nuevo lugar en Nueva York
donde son mayores las multitudes -- la Zona Cero
Turista: He traído a mi hijastra aquí desde Indianápolis.
Este fue -- de todos los sitios turísticos en la Ciudad de Nueva York --
su primera elección.
JA: Miles ahora se alinean en el Bajo Brodway.
Turista: He querido bajar aquí desde que esto pasó.
JA: Aún en los días más fríos del Invierno.
Para honrar y recordar.
Turista: Es la realidad, somos nosotros. Ocurrió aquí.
Esto es nuestro.
JA: Tantos, de hecho, que el ver se ha convertido
en algo problemático.
Turista: Pero pienso que la gente está muy frustrada
de no poder acercarse para ver lo que sucede.
JA: Pero eso está a punto de cambiar.
En tiempo récord,
un equipo de arquitectos y trabajadores de la construcción
han diseñado y construido una plataforma mirador para aliviar la frustración --
y acercar más a la gente.
Hombre: Tendrán un panorama increíble.
Y entenderán, pienso que de manera más completa,
la absoluta totalidad de la destrucción del lugar.
JA: Si se piensa al respecto, la Zona Cero es diferente
de la mayoría de otros sitios turísticos en América.
Diferente del Gran Cañón o el Monumento a Washington,
la gente viene aquí para ver lo que ya no sigue allí.
David Rockwell: La primera experiencia que la gente tendrá aquí,
cuando vea esto, que no es como una obra de construcción,
pero como este increíblemente conmovedor camposanto.
JA: Las paredes están desnudas por diseño, de manera que la gente pueda llenarlas
con sus propios conmemoraciones de la misma manera que ya lo han hecho
alrededor del perímetro actual.
Turista: Desde nuestros corazones, nos afectó igualmente.
JA: Las rampas son hechas de materiales simples --
del tipo de madera contrachapada que se observa en los sitios de construcción --
lo cual es realmente el punto.
Ante la presencia de la peor destrucción en América,
la gente construye de nuevo.
Jim Axelrod, Noticias CBS, Nueva York.
KA: Este no es un tema obvio para estar en el segmento de sensualidad,
pero ciertamente, David, eres conocido como -- lo sé, una frase que odias --
un arquitecto del entretenimiento.
Tu trabajo es ampliamente sensual, inclusive hedonista.
DR: Me gusta esa palabra.
KA: Está bien. Es acerca del placer -- casinos, hoteles y restaurantes.
¿Cómo la impresión que todos nosotros -- y especialmente todos nosotros en Nueva York --
sentimos el 11 de Septiembre se convierte
en tu deseo de hacer ésto?
DR: Bueno, la verdad es que posterior al 11 de Septiembre,
me sentí a mi mismo en el rol original --
primeramente de alguien que vive en Tribeca
y cuya vecindad fue devastada,
y como alguien que trabaja a menos de una milla de aquí --
que estaba en la posición de forzar 100 personas que trabajan conmigo,
en mi firma, para continuar con el mismo nivel de entusiasmo,
para crear los lugares que hemos venido creando.
De hecho, estamos terminando un libro que se llama "Placer,"
el cual se refiere a placer sensual en espacios.
Pero tengo que decirte -- se hizo imposible el hacer aquello.
Estábamos realmente paralizados.
y me encontré a mi mismo el viernes siguiente al 11 de Septiembre --
dos días después --
literalmente imposibilitado de motivar a nadie ni de hacer ninguna cosa.
Dimos unos días libres en la oficina.
Y al discutir ésto con otros arquitectos,
habíamos visto gente diciendo en la prensa
que debían reconstruirse las torres tal como estaban --
y rehacerse con 50 pisos adicionales.
Y pensé que era asombroso el especular
como si esto fuera una competición,
sobre algo que era una herida tan fresca.
Y tuve una serie de discusiones --
primero con Rick Scofidio y Liz Diller, quienes colaboraron con nosotros en ésto,
y muchas otras personas --
y realmente sentí como que teníamos que encontrar la relevancia en hacer algo.
Y que como gente que crea lugares, la manera fundamental de ayudar
no era la de pontificar o hacer escenarios,
sino ayudar ahora mismo.
Así que tratamos de pensar en una manera,
como grupo, de tener una especial de Grupo SWAT de Diseño.
Y esa fue la misión que hemos encontrado.
KA: Estabas consciente de que súbitamente --
como un diseñador cuyo trabajo es todo acerca de cumplir requerimientos --
súbitamente satisfaciendo necesidades?
DR: Bueno, de lo que estaba consciente era,
que había esta abrumadora necesidad de actuar ahora mismo.
Y que nos habían pedido el participar en unos pocos proyectos antes que ésto.
Había una escuela, PS 234, que había sido evacuada abajo en la Zona Cero.
Se mudaron a una escuela abandonada.
Llevamos 20 o 30 arquitectos y diseñadores y artistas,
y en el espacio de cuatro días -- era como un levantamiento de granja urbana
para renovarlo, y todos quería ayudar.
Fue simplemente extraordinario.
Tom Otterness contribuyó, Maira Kalman contribuyó
y se convirtió en una experiencia catártica para nosotros.
KA: Y esto fue hecho, efectivamente, en tres semanas --
¿Hacia Octubre Ocho más o menos?
DR: Sí.
KA: Obviamente, lo que enfrentaron al tratar de hacer algo
tan sustancial como este proyecto -- y éste es sólo uno de cuatro
que han diseñado para rodear el sitio --
deben haber entrado en conflicto con la increiblemente bizantina,
y atrincherada burocracia y los poderes establecidos
en las Bienes Raíces y la Política de Nueva York.
DR: Bueno, es algo gracioso.
Terminamos PS 234, y cenamos con un grupo pequeño.
Me pidieron, de hecho, que fuese un líder de un comité del Instituto Americano de Arquitectos, para reconstruir.
Y participé en varias reuniones.
Y había allí los planes mas del tipo de grandes circuitos
que tenían que ver con infraestructura de largo plazo y reconstruir la ciudad entera.
Y el hecho es que había heridas inmediatas y necesidades que debían ser satisfechas,
y se habló acerca de la inclusión y que se quería que fuese un proceso incluyente.
Y no era un grupo incluyente.
Así que dijimos, lo que es --
KA: ¿No era un grupo incluyente?
DR: No era un grupo incluyente.
Era predominantemente un grupo corporativo de blancos y ricos
que no era representativo de la ciudad.
KA: ¡Sorprendente!
DR: Sí, sorprendente.
Así que Rick, Liz, Kevin y yo diseñamos la idea.
La ciudad de hecho nos contactó.
Y nosotros primeramente le tocamos a la ciudad el tema del muelle 94.
Vimos como el PS 234 funcionó.
Las familias -- las víctimas de las familias --
iban a este muelle que era increíblemente deshumanizante.
KA: ¿En el Río Hudson?
DR: Sí. Y la ciudad en realidad -- a través de Tim Zagat inicialmente,
y después a través de Chrystine Nicholas, después llegamos a Giuliani --
dijo, sabes, no queremos nada que ver con el Muelle 94 en este momento,
pero tenemos una plataforma observador para las familias abajo en la Zona Cero
que quisieramos que fuese una experiencia mas dignificante para las familias,
y una manera de protegerla del clima.
Así que fui allá abajo con Rick, Liz y Kevin,
y tengo que decir, que fue la experiencia mas conmovedora de mi vida.
fue devastador ver la simple plataforma de contracenchapado con un baranda alrededor de ella,
donde las familias de las víctimas habían dejado notas para ellos.
Y no había mediación entre nosotros y la experiencia.
No había filtro.
Y recordé el 11 de Septiembre en la calle 14,
en el techo de nuestro edificio -- podíamos ver las torres del World Trade prominentemente
y yo vi el primer edificio colapsar desde una sala de conferencias
en el piso 8, en una televisión que habíamos instalado.
Y entonces todos estaban arriba en el techo, y corrí allí.
Y era impresionante cuanto mas duro era
el creerlo en la vida real que en la Televisión.
Había algo en la comodidad del filtro
y, sabes, cuanta información había entre nosotros y la experiencia.
Así que el ver esto de una manera sencilla,
y digna fue una experiencia muy poderosa.
Así que fuimos de vuelta a la Ciudad y les dijimos,
no estamos particularmente interesados en elevar esto a una plataforma VIP,
pero hemos pasado algún tiempo allá abajo.
Y al mismo tiempo la Ciudad tenía esta necesidad.
Buscaban una solución
para tratar con 30 o 40 mil personas diarias
que estaban yendo allá abajo, que no tenían ningún lugar a dónde ir.
Y no había manera de controlar el tráfico alrededor del sitio.
Así que ocuparse de esto es justo un plan maestro inmediato.
Había una manera -- tenía que haber una manera --
para hacer que la gente se moviera alrededor del sitio.
KA: Pero entonces tienes que encontrar una manera --
nos saltaremos los insanamente fastidiosos procesos de obtener permisos
e involucrando a todos -- pero simplemente para financiar esto.
Parece que es, sabes, algo muy simple.
¿Pero éste fue un proyecto de medio millón de dólares?
DR: Bueno, sabíamos que si no era financiado por la empresa privada,
no iba a concretarse.
Y sabíamos también, francamente, que si no se concretaba
hacia el final de la administración Giuliani,
todos aquellos con quienes tratabamos en el Departamento de Transportes,
y el Departamento de Policía y todos los --
estábamos reuniéndonos con 20 o 30 personas con la Ciudad en ese momento.
y fue todo montado por la Oficina de Gestión de Emergencias.
Este acto increíble por parte de ellos, porque ellos realmente querían esto,
y sentían que esto necesitaba ocurrir.
KA: ¿Y había entonces este reloj haciendo tictac?
¿Porque Giuliani estaba obviamente fuera tres meses después de eso?
Sí. Así que lo primero que debíamos hacer era encontrar una manera de llegar a esto --
teníamos que trabajar con las familias de las víctimas,
a través de la Ciudad, para asegurarnos que ellos sabían que esto estaba ocurriendo.
Ya que esto no quería ser como una sorpresa.
Y teníamos además que estar tan debajo de radares como se puede estar en Nueva York,
ya que la clave era no levantar muchas objeciones
y casi tratar de trabajar tan discretamente como fuese posible.
Llegamos a la conclusión de organizar una fundación,
principalmente porque cuando encontrasemos un contratista que edificara ésto,
el no acordaría el hacerlo, aún cuando le pagasemos el dinero.
Se necesitaba tener una fundación.
Así que organizamos una fundación, y realmente lo que pasó fue
que un promotor inmobiliario grande en nueva York --
KA: Que debería mantenerse innombrado, ¿supongo?
DR: Sí. Sus iniciales son JS, y el es dueño del Centro Rockefeller,
si eso ayuda a alguien -- y se hizo voluntario para ayudar.
Y nos encontramos con él.
Los precios de los contratistas fueron entre quinientos a setecientos mil dólares.
Y Atlantic-Heydt, la cual es la contratista más grande de andamiaje en el pais,
se ofreció para hacerlo al costo.
Así que este promotor dijo, "Saben que, avalaremos los gastos totales."
Y dijimos, "¡Esto es increíble!"
Y pienso que esto fue el 21,
y sabíamos que esto debía estar erigido para el 28.
Y teníamos que comenzar la construcción el día siguiente.
Tuvimos una reunión esa noche con el contratista elegido,
y el contratista se apareció con los planos de la plataforma
aproximadamente de la mitad del tamaño que nosotros la habíamos dibujado.
KA: Casi como la escena de Spinal Tap dónde sale
el pequeñísimo Stonehenge, ¿supongo?
(Risas)
DR: De hecho, era como si esto iba a tener andamiaje para lavar ventanas.
No había una sensación de que esto es -- después de Saint Paul --
que este es realmente un lugar que necesita ser dignificado de alguna manera,
y un lugar para reflexionar y recordar.
y tengo que decir que invertimos mucho tiempo,
en juntar ésto, mirando las multitudes que se reunían en Saint Paul --
el cual se encuentra justo a la derecha -- y moviéndonos alrededor del sitio.
Y yo vivo allá abajo, así que estuvimos mucho tiempo viendo la necesidad.
Y pienso que la gente estaban sorprendidas de dos cosas --
Pienso que estaban impresionadas por la destrucción,
pero pienso que había una sensación de incredulidad
acerca del heroísmo de los Neoyorkinos que yo encontré muy conmovedor.
Just el tipo de heroísmo cotidiano de los Neoyorkinos.
Así que estábamos en esta reunión, y el contratista literalmente dijo,
"Voy a cerrar la puerta con llave, ya que este urbanizador
no aceptará que ustedes se vayan hasta que hayan cerrado este caso."
Y dijimos, "Bueno, éste es la mitad del tamaño,
no tiene ninguna de las características de diseño
que han sido acordadas por todos -- todos en la ciudad.
Tendríamos que volver al principio para hacer ésto."
Y lo convencí de que debíamos salir de la habitación
con el acuerdo de construir como fue diseñado.
El día siguiente recibí un correo electrónico del urbanizador
diciendo que estaba retirando todo el financiamiento.
Así que no sabíamos qué hacer,
pero decidimos lanzar una red muy amplia.
Enviamos nuestras cartas por correo electrónico a toda la gente que pudimos --
varias personas en la audiencia aquí -- que fueron de mucha ayuda.
KA: ¿No hubo la idea de abandonar el barco en ese momento?
DR: No. De hecho le dije al contratista que siguiese adelante.
Ya él había solicitado materiales basado en mi aprobación.
Sabíamos que de una manera u otra, esto iba a darse.
Y sentimos que tenía que darse.
KA: Estaban financiándose ustedes mismos, entonces, con contribuciones y esta fundación.
Richard, pienso que muy correctamente,
trató este punto al comienzo --
antes que todos los diseñadores de sillas salieran --
acerca de la historia de los diseñadores de sillas imponiendo soluciones estéticas
en este tipo de problema universal, banal y común de sentarse.
Me parece a mi con ésto,
que era el contrario de aquello.
Porque este era un problema de diseño particular y sin precedentes.
DR: Bueno, he aquí el asunto.
Sabiámos que esto no era en el sentido de --
pensamos en el sitio, y pensamos en la necesidad de un monumento.
Era importante que ésto no fuese categorizado como un monumento.
Que este era un lugar para que la gente reflexionara, para que recordara --
un lugar del tipo sosegado.
Así que nos llevó a usar soluciones de diseño
que crearon menos filtros entre el espectador --
como dijimos acerca de la plataforma de las familias -- y la experiencia en lo posible.
Es todo un material increíblemente humilde.
Es andamiaje y contraenchapado.
Y permite -- por la procesión del movimiento,
arriba por Saint Paul y abajo del otro lado,
te da unos 300 pies para subir 13 pies desde el suelo,
para el sitio dónde tendrás la vista de 360 grados.
Pero el diseño fue impulsado por una necesidad de ser rápidos, económicos, seguros, respetuosos, flexibles.
Una de las otras cosas es que esto está diseñado para que pueda moverse.
Porque cuando miramos a las cuatro plataformas alrededor del sitio,
uno de los cuales es una mejora a la plataforma de las familias,
supimos que éstas debían ser móviles
para responder al cambio en las condiciones,
y la definición cambiante de lo que la Zona Cero es.
KA: Tu trabajo -- quiero decir, hemos hablado de esto antes --
mucho de tu trabajo, pienso, está informado por tu creencia, o tu enfoque en,
la temporalidad de todas las cosas y la fugacidad de las cosas.
Y un tipo de "Come, bebe, y sé alegre, ya que mañana moriremos,"
sentido de la existencia.
Esto es claramente no es un trabajo para las eras.
Sabes, en un par de años esta cosa no va a estar aquí.
¿Eso requirió, como arquitecto,
una nueva manera de pensar acerca de lo que estabas haciendo?
¿Para pensar en esto como una instalación puramente temporal?
DR: No, no lo creo así
Pienso que esto es, obviamente, sustancialmente diferente
de cualquier cosa que habíamos pensado hacer aquí antes, solo por su propia naturaleza.
Donde se superpone con pensamientos acerca de nuestra obra en general es,
número uno -- la noción de colaboración como una manera de lograr que las cosas se hagan.
Y Kevin Kennon, Rick Scofidio, Liz Diller
y toda la gente en la Ciudad --
Norman Lear, con quien hablé incluso 4 horas antes de nuestra fecha tope de financiamiento,
ofreció darnos un préstamo puente para ayudarnos a conseguirlo.
Así que la noción de colaboración --
Pienso que ésto refuerza cuan importante es.
Y en términos de su naturaleza temporal,
nuestra meta no era el crear algo
que estuviese allí más tiempo del necesario.
Pienso que estábamos más interesados en promover un tipo de diálogo
que sentíamos que podía no estar pasando lo suficiente esta ciudad,
acerca de lo que realmente está pasando aquí.
Y un día o dos antes de que abriera era el discurso de despedida de Giuliani,
donde él propuso la idea de que toda la Zona Cero fuese un monumento.
Lo cual era muy controversial pero resonó en mucha gente.
Y pienso que sin importar cuál es la posición acerca de cómo
esta pieza sagrada de tierra será usada,
y haciendole salir a la luz del hecho de verla en un encuentro real,
Pienso, que lo hace un diálogo más poderoso.
Y es en eso en lo que estábamos interesados.
Así que eso está, enfáticamente, en el reino de las cosas
en las que me he interesado antes.
KA: Me parece a mí, enter otras cosas, una encantadora pieza de infraestructura cívica.
Le permite a la conversación tornarse seria.
Y seis meses después del hecho --
y sólo unos pocos meses antes de que el sitio fuese limpiado --
estamos muy rápidamente, ahora, llegando al punto
donde las conversaciones acerca de lo que debería ir allí se ponen serias.
¿Tienes -- habiendo estado tan físicamente involucrado en el sitio
como lo has estado, haciendo este proyecto -- algunas ideas acerca
de lo que debería o no hacerse?
DR: Bueno, pienso que algo que no debería hacerse es evaluar --
Pienso que ahora mismo la discusión está muy centrada en el plan maestro.
La Galería Protetch recientemente tuvo una muestra de ideas para edificios,
la cual tuvo algunas ideas ingeniosas para edificios.
KA: Pero tenía algunas ideas realmente terribles.
DR: Y también se sintió un poco como una suerte de competencia de ideas,
donde pienso que el foco de las ideas debe estar en el planeamiento maestro y usos.
Y pienso que debería ampliarse -- lo cual está comenzando a ser.
¿El diálogo está realmente abriéndose hacia,
hacia lo que este sitio realmente quiere ser?
Y verdaderamente pienso hasta que el asunto del monumento se decida,
que va a ser muy difícil el tener una discusión inteligente.
Hay pocas discusiones ahora mismo que pienso que son muy positivas
acerca de bajar la Autopista del Lado Oeste y conectar esto,
para que haya un solo pedazo de tierra sin interrupciones.
KA: Bueno, pienso que es interesante.
Y esto lleva a otro asunto que era probablemente inapropiado
de discutir hace seis meses, pero tal vez no ahora,
que es, no a muchos de nosotros nos gusta el Centro de Comercio Mundial como una pieza de Arquitectura,
tanto como lo que le había hecho a esta ciudad, y esa inmensa plaza.
Es ésta una oportunidad, es ésta una oportunidad en la adversidad --
una oportunidad esperanzadora, aqui -- para reconstruir
una malla citadina mas tradicional, ¿o no?
DR: Pienso que hay una oportunidad real de comenzar
una discusión del porqué vivimos en ciudades.
Y de ¿Por qué vivimos en lugares donde gente tan diferente
chocan con nosotros cada día?
No pienso que tenga mucho que ver con 50 o 60 o 70 u 80 mil nuevos espacios de oficinas,
sin importar cuál es el número.
Así que si, pienso que hay una oportunidad de mirar de nuevo el cómo pensamos acerca de las ciudades
Y de hecho, hay una propuesta en la mesa para el edificio número siete.
KA: ¿Era ese el edificio que estaba al Norte de las Torres?
DR: Correcto, sobre el cual las Torres cayeron.
Y la razón por la cual está paralizado es la indignación de la comunidad
ya que ellos no están re-abriendo la calle
para conectar aquello de vuelta con el resto de la Ciudad.
Así que pienso que un diálogo público -- Creo, sabes,
Me gustaría ver una competencia internacional,
y un llamado a las ideas para los usos.
KA: Ya sean las artes, ya sea la vivienda,
¿Ya sea el monto de las compras?
DR: Correcto. Y estamos buscando otras cosas.
Esta pequeña fundación que hemos creado busca por otras maneras de ayudar.
Incluyendo el tomar una pequeña pieza adyacente al sitio
e invitar a 10 arquitectos que actualmente no tienen Voz
en Nueva York para hacer alojamiento para artistas.
Y encontrar otras maneras de animar la discusión
para estar en contra de las soluciones únicas y monolíticas,
y mas a favor de la multiplicidad de las cosas.
KA: Antes que terminemos, sé que tienes una pieza de vídeo digital
¿Sobre la experiencia de estar en esta plataforma?
DR: John Kamen -- que está aquí de hecho -- creó
una pieza de dos minutos y medio que muestra la plataforma en uso.
Así que pensé que sería bueno finalizar con ella.
DR: Estamos viendo desde la Calle Fulton, Oeste.
Uno de los asuntos difíciles que teníamos con la Administración Giuliani
era, que yo había olvidado cuan anti-graffiti él era.
Y esencialmente nuestra estructura fue diseñada para escribir sobre ella.
KA: Como tu bien dices, no es un monumento.
¿Pero eran ustedes conscientes de los monumentos?¿El monumento a Vietnam?
¿Este tipo de formas?
DR: Ciertamente hicimos tanta investigación como pudimos,
y estábamos conscientes de otros monumentos.
Y también de la complejidad y cantidad de tiempo que toman hacerse.
Son 350 personas en el comité de la Ciudad de Oklahoma,
por lo cual pensamos en esto como una solución espontánea y apropiada
que se expandió hasta la Plaza de la Unión
y los lugares que ya eran monumentos a propósito en la ciudad.
El andamiaje que puedes ver montado sobre la calle es desmontable.
Lo interesante ahora es que la naturaleza del sitio ha cambiado totalmente,
de manera que estás al tanto de
que no es sólo la destrucción de los edificios en la Zona Cero,
pero además de todos los edificios alrededor de ella --
y las cicatrices en los edificios alrededor de ella, las cuales son enormes.
Esto muestra Saint Paul a la izquierda.
KA: Sólo quiero agradecerte en nombre de los Neoyorkinos
por hacer que esto sucediera y haber hecho ésto.
Pero la naturaleza casi virtualmente instantánea de su edificación,
y el hecho de que esté allí,
casi antes de que puedas creer
que una respuesta de esta magnitud pueda ser lograda,
es parte de su, pienso, extraordinaria --
No sé si belleza es la palabra --
pero su presencia.
DR: Fue un honor hacerlo.
Y estuvimos encantados de poder mostrarlo aquí.